[Musique]
j'ai demandé aussi
aux trois chefs de position de ma
compagnie jeudi pour aller
poser un geste de réconfort auprès de la
population
leur dire tout le Québec tous les partis
tout le monde est avec eux autres c'est
vraiment le drame qui a marqué la
journée aujourd'hui le Québec en entier
sous le choc à leur imaginé pour les
gens qui vivent dans cette toute petite
municipalité d'à peu près 6000 habitants
c'est notre panel politique avec
Véronique prince Michel CEG Christian
Dufour bonsoir à vous tous bonsoir
Véronique clairement c'est un message
d'unité que pouvait montrer les
politiciens aujourd'hui on a vu des gens
qui sont habituellement des adversaires
être côte à côte être unis c'est la
bonne chose à faire dans un drame comme
ça d'autant plus que c'est triste à dire
mais l'ont fait il y a quelques semaines
déjà pour cet autre drame à Laval avec
la garderie donc c'est clair que dans le
code I'm cuir on fait un copier-coller
là c'est à dire que les gens ont quand
même eu commentaires réconfort sur place
quand François Legault et les chiffres
de position c'était rendu à Laval avait
senti justement cette espèce de vague de
soutien et les gens dames Queen méritent
la même chose dans un sens ils agissent
un peu comme eux-mêmes étant des
intervenants psychosociaux c'est un peu
seul rôle du gouvernement dans une
situation comme celle-là c'est pas
nécessairement d'annoncer des choses
d'apporter tout de suite des solutions
mais au moins d'assurer une présence sur
place pour montrer que c'est important
je voudrais vous entendre aussi
Véronique le disait ces deux drames ont
à peu près un mois ça laisse une
impression de dangerosité il y a quelque
part il y avait vraiment dans le message
des politiciens ce qu'on entendait
aujourd'hui une obligation de rassurer
la population non le monde n'est pas
plus dangereux monsieur bonardel le
disait on peut encore sortir dehors et
faire marcher son chien là
je pense que le rôle des politiciens
c'est beaucoup en fait d'apporter du
réconfort de faire partie en fait d'un
système d'assistance psycho social on
est en fait jusqu'à nouvel ordre en face
du logique de la vie donc des choses qui
sont qui arrivent depuis toujours et qui
vont arriver toujours je m'excuse de le
rappeler c'est un fait divers
extrêmement poignant tragique mais je
pense qu'il faut résister dans un
premier temps la tentation de dire au
gouvernement fait quelque chose là c'est
de la faute de
la faute de personne c'est c'est notre
condition d'être humain dans ce sens
monsieur bonardelle que vous avez
intervie tantôt c'était intéressant
parce que dans un premier temps comme il
le dit c'est mis à réfléchir tout haut
et je pense que c'est une gaffe quand
c'est commencé tout de suite à parler de
la possibilité de suspendre les permis
de conduire
si vous voulez on va entendre l'extrait
où il le dit c'était pendant une
entrevue à la radio la Radio-Canada ce
matin et on va l'entendre un peu plus
tard dans la journée finalement essayer
de rétrober d'aller un petit peu on va
voir ce que ça donne
[Applaudissements]
des problématiques fixes est-ce que le
suivi a été bien fait par les médecins
et par la suite est-ce que ces personnes
peuvent obtenir un permis de congé
vous savez quand on est ministre on
essaie de trouver des pistes de solution
puis souvent mon équipe n'est pas quand
je passe avoir autre j'ai pensé avoir au
matin donc on comprenne bien là on
entreprend pas une exercice au
gouvernement suite à ça il faut
comprendre que il y a des problématiques
oui de santé pour certaines personnes
mais au-delà de tout ça il y a des de
Line qui est disponible
vous parliez du risque justement de
réfléchir à voix haute pour un
politicien oui heureusement il aurait
trop pédalé parce que c'est tentant en
fait de dire les gens disent faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose c'est pas normal et
là c'est le gouvernement moi je critique
Bruxelles parce que un processus de
déresponsabilité des individus puis je
me répète là mais à moins qu'on ait
d'autres preuves d'autres éléments c'est
le trajet de la vie qui est là que
toujours été là qui va toujours rester
là Michel il était beaucoup question
pendant la journée de santé mentale on a
entendu monsieur Legault en parler on a
entendu d'autres politiciens l'évoquer
aussi mais en fait on ne connaît pas les
motivations de cette personne on en sait
bien peu sur l'accusé dans les faits ce
qu'on sait par contre c'est que et ça
c'est Monsieur karma qui le dit ça a été
rapporté par le Premier ministre il y a
eu une hausse des demandes de gens qui
consultent depuis quelques années 44%
semble-t-il et on sait qu'on n'arrive
pas à répondre à toutes les demandes il
y a des listes d'attente c'est un fait
ça fait et c'est une bonne chose que
plus de gens demandent de l'aide chaque
fois qu'une tragédie comme ça on dit
n'hésitez pas à demander de l'aide si
vous en avez si vous avez besoin d'aide
c'est une bonne chose quand même mais là
on se rend compte que on a passé de
ressources et il va falloir que le
gouvernement il fait 6 là dedans et je
suis d'accord avec Christiane ça c'est
une tragédie de la vie puis on peut pas
la prévoir on peut pas mais on peut se
dire ensemble
tenter maintenant pour notre système de
santé pendant très longtemps et il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose
quand ta situation politique de ça
monsieur bollardin
il y a un ministre doit jamais réfléchir
tout haut je me souviens que c'est pas
le Martin avait dit que c'était devenu
premier ministre assez collègues la
première chose qu'il aura même si c'est
ne réfléchissez pas tout quand on a
quelque chose à dire
alors
parce que ça ça peut causer toutes
sortes d'autres problèmes
il faut vraiment faire attention à ça
parce que dans une crise comme ça les
gens voient pas toutes l'information non
plus puissent le gouvernement dit ça
alors que c'était pas ça effectivement
des perceptions et un certain
ostréisation aussi des gens qui
souffrent de problèmes de santé mentale
Véronique parfois les politiciens sont
aussi des humains monsieur bonardel par
moments quand ils ont entendu parler
dans la journée on le sentait aussi je
dirais pas dépasser par les événements
mais particulièrement touché comme à
commettre humain illuministre la
sécurité publique mais il n'a pas toutes
les réponses il peut pas protéger tout
le monde compte tout c'est sûr qu'on
peut l'excuser en disant ben il était en
pleine gestion de crise c'est pas
quelqu'un normalement c'est pas le
ministre qui est reconnu non plus pour
faire des erreurs c'est assez rare que
ce genre de choses là ce produit avec
François Bonnardel mais en même temps il
a assez d'expérience pour savoir qu'on
ne peut pas pouvoir réfléchir à voix
haute parce qu'effectivement ça peut
créer une diversion négative en pleine
crise puis choquer encore plus et les
gens pas besoin d'être choqué encore
plus donc au moins il a essayé pendant
la journée justement de remettre la
pantalon dans le tube mais quand même là
je pense qu'il aura appris de ses
erreurs parce qu'il va être appelé
probablement intervenir sur d'autres
gestion de crise comme ça là
quand tu es ministre de la Sécurité
publique je pense qu'il faut que tu
contrôles sur tes émotions et
deuxièmement heureusement il aurait trop
pédaler de façon très très clair je
pense que moi je veux vraiment qu'on
arrête de toujours faire appel au
gouvernement
instinctivement il faut être rigoureux
aussi là dessus je suis qu'un nouvel
ordre là c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
pouvait prévenir donc faut s'en sortir à
ça puis aussi évidemment à exprimer
notre support notre chagrin tout ça mais
lui dise la sécurité publique est pas là
pour exprimer ses émotions alors voilà
donc on sait qu'ils vont tous être
présent les le Premier ministre les
chefs plus d'opposition jeudi donc ce
sera à suivre mais toujours en montrant
ce message d'unité puis rappelons cette
bonne note là c'est deux petits enfants
qui étaient parmi les victimes qui ont
été libérées aujourd'hui de l'hôpital
donc ça veut dire qu'il se porte bien
c'est au moins une note positive pour
terminer ce sujet on va revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé hier parce que ça a été
pratiquement évacué par le drame que il
y avait une élection partielle hier on
en a parlé pendant toutes les semaines
qui précédaient il faudrait toujours
bien qu'on analyse les résultats
aujourd'hui alors victoire éclatante de
Québec solidaire dansé Henri Sainte-Anne
c'est donc leur candidats Guillaume
Cliche River qui l'a emporté on voit
vraiment avec une large avance 44% pour
Québec solidaire et 28% pour le Parti
libéral vous êtes tous des analystes
tout le monde disait ça va être serré ça
va être difficile
votre analyse Christian bah c'est que
pour Québec solidaire c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle parce que depuis la
dernière élection il y avait besoin
d'une victoire donc une victoire qui est
symbolique dans l'ancien comté en fait
le chef du parti libéral elle est claire
la victoire c'est un candidat de qualité
qui est enracinant dans le comté
Guillaume cliché Rivard donc pour eux ça
arrive au bon moment aussi c'est dans la
lignée de certaines analyses qu'on ne
lui allait faire que le véritable
compétiteur de Québec solidaire ce
serait le Parti libéral dans les deux
cas ce sont des parties qui sont pas
nationalistes beaucoup pour la
crédibilité indépendanteuse de Québec
solidaire et pour le moins très très
faible puis aussi on va être intéressant
de voir dans ce contenu là où il y a
quand même le tiers la population qui
était anglophone jusqu'à quel point il y
a des anglophones ou des non
francophones qui ont voté pour un Québec
solidaire donc c'est vraiment une
défaite au détriment du delibéraux mais
ça fait pas vraiment la CAC et le PQ
d'ailleurs performer relativement ment
bien là-dedans donc c'est intéressant
mais en finale le paradoxe en fait
l'ironie c'est que ce nouveau
candidat-là qui est de qualité que de la
classe qui est très efficace c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui est un avocat en
immigration qui plaide beaucoup pour une
immigration je trouve des fois un petit
peu angélique et moi je trouve ça peut
nuire à Québec solidaire dans ces
tentatives de conquérir l'ensemble des
Québécois des francophones qui sont plus
réticents à l'égard de l'immigration
dans le contexte du chemin Roxane puis
dans le contexte aussi de la crise
comme ça parce qu'il est très bon le
gars mais si il se met à parler de façon
trop efficace et l'immigration parfois
ça peut avoir des conséquences qui sont
pas prévues en fait j'entends Véronique
aussi là-dessus parce que c'est un
château fort libéral Veronique alors je
dirais on a vu monsieur Tanguy essayer
de s'expliquer de soulever toutes sortes
de questions nos valeurs mais comment on
va passer le message en fait on a
l'impression qu'on a pas plus avancé
depuis la dernière élection générale
toujours les mêmes questions qui sont
sur la table et les réponses on les
cherche toujours dans le parti mais faut
pas oublier que dans cette partie là
Québec Solidaire a déployé la machine
puissant non une machine aux élections
générales les militants étaient
dispersés un petit peu partout mais là
ils étaient concentrés ils étaient 680
sur le terrain puis peut-être que je
suis de la vieille école mais je pense
encore que faire du porte-à-porte tu es
allé directement à la rencontre des gens
ça peut être payant même en 2023 donc
de son côté le Parti libéral je doute du
militantisme à quel point il est encore
fort parce que justement campagne
électorale quand je m'étais rendu dans 5
ans et que j'avais parlé à des militants
que je vois souvent j'ai souvent couvert
des congrès des événements du Parti
libéral où on revoit les mêmes visages
puis je me rappelle très bien qu'il y
avait une militante qui m'avait dit
c'est plus que c'était le militantisme
au Parti libéral j’enfant encore mais
j'ai pu le goût d'en faire comme avant
mais pourquoi Véronique elle me disait
il y a plus l'ambiance familiale qu'on
avait autrefois quand les familles
débarquaient avec de la bouffe on
partager tout c'était notre activité
sociale puis en 2016 fait quand même 6-7
ans là il y avait eu un rapport de
Jérôme Turcotte a mis le temps de longue
date où justement on disait qu'il
fallait relancer militantisme ça
commence à dater et je me demande si
vraiment ça a été fait visiblement non
selon ce que me disait cette militante
là et Michel votre analyse
je vais noter une chose de sucre et le
seul candidat qui habite le côté d'une
part et qui était candidate dans ce
côté-là
étaient tous candidats mais dans des
côtés souvent même très éloignés juste
le candidat libéral qui vient du côté
voisin mais Sainte-Marie Saint-Jean
c'est pas du tout le même monde ça c'est
la première des choses à leur état reste
au milieu ça compte encore deuxièmement
il y a un bout de la recette du Parti
libéral qui n'est plus là on se disait
s'il y a plus que 25% d'anglophones dans
un côté c'est un bloc qui va partir
libéral il y a pas besoin d'en gagner
tant que ça pour gagner le côté ce n'est
plus vrai et ça c'est le vrai le vrai
enseignement qui est dangereux pour la
partie libérale hier c'est que ils ne
peuvent plus compter sur un vote non
seulement fidèle de tous les anglophones
mais qui se déplacent pour aller voter
parce que c'était la une communauté où
les gens vont voter c'est plus le cas et
ça c'est vraiment un problème parce que
voici le côté qu'ils auraient dû gagner
et il est incapable de trouver candidat
local
que c'est que souvent quand même
c'est un avocat d'immigration qui
connaît très bien son dossier très
souvent utilisé par les médias à
l'époque tout comme
si j'étais un milieu de l'immigration je
ferais bien attention à la période des
questions à partir de maintenant parce
qu'il peut être tout à table parce que
c'est aussi qui est complexe immigration
va se le dire là nous on a même un
expert ici à Radio-Canada parmi nos
collègues journalistes il y en a qui ont
développé des expertises parce que c'est
pas simple à aborder alors vous êtes
adversaire redoutable parce que lui il
le maîtrise sur le bout des doigts par
contre pour le Parti libéral un parti
pot de chef parce que besoin de trouver
de la relève un verset qui a besoin de
recréer de l'attraction et ce tanguille
disait il faut qu'on se redéfinisse au
cannelle on incarne nos valeurs Michel
la suite c'est quoi pour ce partie là
et la redéfinition des valeurs va
beaucoup se faire par le débat au lieu
de Chypre qui va venir et qui vont être
intéressant mais
il va falloir que les libéraux arrêtent
de dire nous on a la recette c'est la
communauté anglophone c'est le fait on a
gagné 10 ans d'élection des Allemands
référendum par rapport aux autres
alors il faut remettre ça en question et
un congrès du logique c'est une bonne
façon de remettre ça en question encore
faut-il qu'il y ait plusieurs candidats
intéressants puis un choc d'idée un peu
plutôt qu'un espèce de couronnement et
personne veut y aller mais ok on va
prendre lui là alors bref ils ont un
lendemain de veille qui est douloureux
aujourd'hui parlons de la 5 monsieur le
goût a fait une sortie aujourd'hui quand
il a été questionné à la suite du drame
d'amkoui clairement il veut que de la
SAC rentre des comptes que ça direction
que son conseil d'administration rendent
des comptes
est-ce que c'est quoi un peu facile pour
Monsieur le goût de dire quelque chose
comme ça parce que tous les partis
d'opposition la tête tournée vers
monsieur Ker c'est le Ministre du
numérique c'était toujours bien un
virage numérique à la SAQ très content
qu'ils disent ça monsieur Lego parce que
je craignais que face à un dossier qui
est objectivement honteux puis qui
menace tout le monde moi tous les matins
je vérifie dans mon portefeuille chez ma
mon permis de conduire est-ce que je
perds tout puis tu perds pas mis de
conduire tu étais dans la merde et moi
j'ai craignais que il y a personne de
responsable vraiment je crois pas que tu
es parti de position je politique
monsieur mais je trouve que ça se défend
très bien que au moins dans un premier
temps on se demanda la SAC là c'est une
société d'État qui est quand même
beaucoup d'autonomie par rapport au
gouvernement que le président de la
santé juste un petit mot là-dessus un
mot de la fin Véronique là-dessus alors
on comprend que vous vous dites c'est
bien ils sont il faut qu'il rentre des
comptes Véronique il faut que la
culpabilité
ministérielle puis il a une épée de
Damoclès le pddie de le PDG de la SAQ
moi ce que je décolle de monsieur
Legault c'est qu'on change pas le
capitaine en pleine tempête mais on
dirait qu'il vit sur du temps emprunter
d'après ce qu'il a dit alors à suivre
comme on dit souvent dans notre langage
merci beaucoup Véronique Michel et
Christian bonne soirée merci bonsoir au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI